[Applause]
[Music]
video games have been a great way to
stay busy these last few months and that
won't be changing in July the coming
month has a bunch of hot new games from
big-name developers that I know I can't
wait to play and I bet you'll find
something to get hyped for too so let's
break down some of the biggest games of
July flying out of the gate first is
Marvel's Ironman VR if you've ever
wanted to suit up like Tony the of the
comic book one not me now's your chance
the game actually has a new suit called
the impulse armor but you'll still be
able to see Friday in your HUD as you
zoom through the sky and fire your
repulsor beams at enemies there might
not be many new superhero movies out
right now but you can still play as one
on psvr on Friday July 3rd speaking of
firing off weapons in the sky let's talk
about rocket arena as the name might
imply this 3v3 team shooter arms you
with nothing but rocket launchers each
character has their own special kind of
rocket though you can level them up to
get new stat boosts and effects - and of
course you'll also have to dodge all the
rockets headed your way
they'll be crashing on the ps4 Xbox one
and PC on Tuesday the 14th and now we'll
move from ranged weapons to the up close
and personal stuff with ghosts of
Tsushima this ps4 exclusive sees the
samurai jinn defending his Island for
Mongol invaders using a combination of
in-your-face katana combat and stealth
the Mongol soldiers are pretty fast with
their own blades so you'll have to
master different stances and counters to
deal with them
sucker punches next adventure is
launching on Friday the 17th and I dunno
what crossover I'd love to see down the
road
mario has to deal with invaders of his
own in paper mario the origami king the
latest entry in the series sees the
Mushroom Kingdom under siege once again
this time by the titular origami king
Ollie the origami style comes into play
as you explore the world bending and
folding things to solve puzzles and
collect coins there's also a new ring
based combat system that challenges you
to line up enemies or make your way to a
bosses weak point you can see it in
action on intend o switch on the 17th
and lastly you can play as the invader
yourself and destroy all humans this
remake puts you in the space boots of
Krypto who sent to a town in the
Midwestern United States to terrorize
the people and harvest their DNA using
all sorts of alien weapons and gadgets
it looks better than the old game of
course but it also includes cut content
from the original you can see the new
stuff on ps4 Xbox one and PC on Tuesday
the 28th and those are some of the
hottest games launching all month long
as always remember that release dates
are based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
everyone and I'll be back with a closer
look at more July games next Sunday
[Music]